le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur je vous
remercie pour cette question et elle a
plusieurs mérites dont celui d'aller
directement sur un vrai sujet de débat
assez technique c'est finalement faut-il
le brassage ou pas des élèves quand le
professeur est absent l'arrière-plan de
votre question c'est aussi un portrait
de la situation si les professeurs ne
sont pas remplacés et de ce point de vue
là c'est très important de souligner ce
que seraient les inconvénients de la
situation si nous n'avions pas eu depuis
le début une grande politique de l'école
ouverte je rappelle que parmi les grands
pays occidentaux nous sommes le pays qui
a maintenu le plus les écoles ouvertes
et ça doit être ça devrait être je crois
que ça doit être un objet de fierté pour
nous tous ici et pour tout l'ensemble du
pays noja de reconnaissance aussi pour
les professeurs et les directeurs
d'école chef d'établissement tous les
personnels et compris les collectivités
locales que je salue parce que nous
savons tous que c'est dur comme c'est
dur pour les parents d'élèves est ce que
je vais dire est que le mois de janvier
est difficile bien sûr que non le mois
de janvier est difficile ils y allaient
situation que vous décrivez qui sont
bien réels et qui sont compliquées
est-ce que nous sommes démunis par
rapport aux problèmes de remplacement
c'est le principal sujet vous avez
évoqué les chiffres devraient quand même
les remettre en situation heureusement
les prévisions du conseil scientifique
ne disent pas qui aura 30 % d'absents il
parle de 30% en additionnant les cas de
malades et les cas contacts et comme
vous le savez ce n'est pas du tout le
même sujet il est impossible de dire
quel sera le pic d'absence mais elle ne
devrait pas dépasser normalement 15% en
tout cas nous nous déployons
actuellement des moyens pour aller au
delà du 9% moyens de remplacement est
allé en effet vers 12 15% le l'absence
cette semaine tels que nous pouvons le
constater elle est de 7 % et donc nous
sommes en ce moment en mesure de
remplacer avec bien entendu des
exceptions il y en a je le reconnais
mais nous sommes en situation d'avoir
cette politique de l'école ouverte qui
correspond au désir de tous des
professeurs des élèves d'ailleurs des
parents d'élèves et de l'ensemble du
pays soyons fiers de cette politique de
l'école ouverte elle reste qu'il faut
pas brassé est-ce qu'il faut ne pas
brasser les les élèves c'est ce que nous
avons fait lorsque nous si nous faisions
linverse il y aurait des questions ici
pour dire à quel point nous faisons des
choses dangereuses d'autant qu'en quoi
qu'on fasse de toutes les façons il ya
ceux qui trouvent qu'on en fait trop
ceux qui trouvent que l'on n'en fait pas
assez cette ligne d'équilibré tissu ce
que recommandent les autorités
sanitaires mais je suis prêt à
reconsidérer dans un dialogue avec les
autorités sanitaires au fil de cette
crise aujourd'hui c'est la règle en tout
cas qui nous permet d'avoir et l'école
ouverte et la sécurité sanitaire
maximale je vous remercie
[Musique]